je reçois maintenant zizi jeanmaire
bonsoir vous heureux de vous avoir en
votre vrai nom c'est vrai que vous avez
bien fait de prendre vie parce que votre
énoncé rené marcel jeanmaire et comme
vous aviez vous n'arriviez pas à dire
rené quand j'étais petit mois vous êtes
au courant de tous et vous qu en asie
oui parce que je vivais ma mère me
disait petit jésus disait oui je suis
ton petit disiez ça m'est resté
voilà voilà et lorsqu incroyable c'est
vraiment une vie un destin votre lice à
rome en quoi c'est à dire vous naissez
un soir où votre main est à l'alhambra
c'est vrai elle va voir trammel et votre
mère à ses premières douleurs pendant le
spectacle
votre père appelle un taxi quand il est
là mais c'est pas dans le taxi devenir
le chien en taxi vous dit ça il vous dit
pas oui il ya votre mère tâchez de
patienter ma petite dame la bagnole est
tout neuf
même si l'issue d'une fabrication ça oui
bah oui surtout que j'ai atterri à
l'alhambra en fait dans la dans
l'endroit du revenu après dans l'endroit
où vous avez quand même si c'est tout un
signe alors votre maire faut dire que
dans la famille votre mère rêvait d'être
chanteuse même nom qui avait déjà des
prédispositions et votre grand père lui
l'avait été au conservatoire de chant
quand il était jeune et ce grand père si
vous aimez beaucoup
un jour il vous a amenée voir roméo
juliette en matinée à garnier et vous
vous avez dit voilà je serai danseuse
c'est aussi c'est fou vous avez quel âge
avait neuf ans oui c'est ça alors j'ai
atterri à l'opéra le même jour la même
année et la même heure carole lombard
oui c'est ça qu'il faut jouer sur votre
vocation je serai dans ce vous avez
jamais douté de votre carrière vous avez
jamais l'impasse et gilles coup de
foudre dès que je me suis mise en
première en seconde etc
j'ai pu attraper la barbe se retrouver
là où à l'opéra garnier faut dire que
quand on arrive à l'opéra garnier quand
on est un canton à cette vision est ce
qu'on se retrouve dans tous ces couloirs
et tout ça c'est extraordinaire
et puis c'est quand même c'est un lieu
magique
elle n'a pas les garder tout de suite de
votre plus jeune âge et j'étais
passionné un tout de suite
alors effectivement on peu de temps
après vous entrez au cours de l'opéra
est alors votre père qui était
industriels et faire ses courses ovale
est allé boire et par des coûts chez
monsieur petit qui était le père de
roland petit il sympathise ils discutent
ensemble de l'avenir de leurs enfants
ils nous mariait déjà ouais c'est ça
nous on en avait pas la moindre idée
parce que ça m'a quand même pris un
certain temps pour le séduit on enfin
par sa ouais il vous mariez oui disait
déjà ici se marier plus tard et tous les
deux ce même amour pour la danse est
retrouvé petit rat tous les deux à l'âge
de à l'âge de 9 ans peu or justement
vous avez vous n'êtes plus le bag
incluant fitch est plus amoureuse de lui
ça m'a pris un certain temps je savais
que de toute façon je ne laissais dirais
que si si j'étais vraiment bien grand
sur scène pas le décevoir centrale d
après ambassades
vous avez passé votre vie elle séduira
pas le décevoir en fait ma vraie
lorsqu'il faut faire s'ils n'y arrivent
pas et vos parents et exige que les
siens donc il dit dans lui quand il
parle de ça il dit qu'il est vous aviez
des bons petits trucs à bouffer mais
qu'est-ce qui rappe qu'on allait avec la
gamelle avez vous fait bien même sous
l'occupation il posséder des paquets
vous savez il y avait il y avait la
douane alors il portait son père
l'emporter à la campagne et revenait et
comment mais ils avaient peur de passer
les fêtes alors il n'en voyait pas de
filmer mur avant de passer la douane et
après faut pas exagérer alors
effectivement vous marier mais ça quand
même plus du tout parce que ça prouve
quand même 23 ans vous êtes mariés en 50
ans 54 alors entre tomber vous a offert
roland petit votre premier triomphe en
49 et carmel en saas et on se rend pas
compte maintenant mais s'était joué à
londres s'était joué à paris s'était
joué à broadway ses nièces qui soient
broyés suivi charleroi de broadway on
est resté marqué les nageurs pendant six
mois
oui et on a été obligé d'arrêter parce
qu'on partait en tournée qu'il avait
ceux signés tout une tournée et on est
revenu l'année d'année avec l'année
d'après avec la crise et ce alors là il
commence roland petit à façonner votre
look vers le côté un peu gaga a vraiment
c'est avec carmen c'est ça qui a tout
décidé de même de ma carrière et ma
transformer mayme vous dit d'aller
roland petit mas plus que façonner il
m'a fait
après bon pour les cheveux c'est
alexandre qui a pris le relais pour les
fringues ccsa laurent 30 30
le pulse et saint-laurent l'idée du pull
avec les collants noirs qui m'étais
tellement bien en valeur vos jambes
c'est saint laurens sweeck on regarde un
petit bout de mon truc en plume parce
que ça ces rituels comme un exil magnéto
m
[Musique]
ouais
5 %
voilà mon truc en plumes à ressasser une
image éternelle quoi c'est à dire ça
vous définissent avoue oui c'est
fantastique je les fais partout dans le
monde et j'étais en afrique j'étais en
amérique j'ai fait partout et même
succès alors oui vous disiez donc un an
après carmen et la croqueuse de diamants
ça c'est vos débuts de chanteuse or là
encore lui l'a fait la mélodie roland
petit alors c'est un oui c'est pas
mélodiste au départ c'est pas il a
toujours adoré faire ça et alors en fait
le camp vous avez chanté la première
fois la croqueuse de diamants il avait
marlène qui étaient dans la salle qui
voulait la chanson il n'y a pas donné
ouais c'est moi qui vais l'enregistrer
vous avez quand même une relation ça
fait longtemps que ça dure on l'a vu
depuis l'âge de 9 ans mais quand même
une relation assez orageuse alors n'a
pas le temps de raconter c'est
malheureux mais tout vote aventure
américaine quand guardiola est mis le
grappin dessus
vous êtes partie des états unis un
moment de rentrer chez vous les pendant
deux ans l'ait pas vu vous avec
guardiola alors de toute façon et piché
et puis j'ai fini par prendre l'avion
vous a dit arrête de pleurer vas-y et
vous et à vous laver les pousser après
mais c'était des histoires en amérique
vous êtes si hollywood quoi lui il est
beau c'est fred astaire pour des dix
l'onglet tourner des films
oui je crois si vous on se rend bien
compte aujourd'hui de ce que ça signifie
c'était fait mais même maintenant se
serait détournée on a fait des tas d
j'ai fait des tournées quand même où je
restais quinze jours à los angeles 15
jours à washington quinze jours à san
francisco et tout ça avec les ballets
après avec le spectacle de l'alhambra
qu'on avait créé à bon nombre alors
bonne force de caractère on la voit dans
un dans un accident qui vous est arrivé
un drame plus tard iv en 75 vous n'êtes
pas là l'opéra depuis 15 ans et puis
vous avez une douleur au tendon
d'achille gauche
et puis vous prenez de la cortisone est
ce que vous savez pas c'est que la
cortisone en fait ça ronge et le pendant
les trois premiers jours ça va
le quatrième soir obligé d'annuler là
vous allez à los angeles vous fait
opérer on vous enlève un petit bout du
du temps dont vous dit vous pouvez plus
jamais dans ces villages ans vous aviez
la jambe gauche plus courte que l'autre
et là vous êtes c'est incroyable vous
êtes revenu vous avez fait de la barre à
terre j'étais chez des poids aux
chevilles c'est ça oui j'ai commencé à
refaire la barre avec des talons hauts
et petit à petit je descendais avec mes
talons pour pouvoir arriver jusqu'au
moment où j'ai fait essayer de faire un
demi plié
enfin je vais pas vous faire un cours de
danse nom à l'un d'eux me priver et
petit à petit j rattrapage à ranger
votre votre temps dont on allonge pas
attendre on allonge le muscle quelle
volonté de toute façon jusqu'à
maintenant je n'ai jamais pensé que je
pouvais m'arrêter j'ai l'âge et la
passion de me retrouver devant un public
parce que j'adore ça c'est une émotion
forte et dure trente dire alors vous
dites vers la preuve c'est que vous
journalistes qu'ils ont demandé à
l'époque quand vous êtes revenu il m'a
alors imaginez que vous soyez pas arrivé
vous avez dit je me serais flinguer donc
c'est vraiment tout le poids de votre
vie dans la presse je m'en serais
flinguer parce qu'il faut avoir beaucoup
de courage pour ses flingues et manteaux
noirs seraient été assez dramatiques
j'aurais bien trouver quelque chose pour
me oui vous êtes super en forme je sais
pas vous demander qu'est ce que vous
faites vous faites très attention mais
j'ai rien vous pouvez pas vous ashwin
pas non je fumais demande malades pas
été facile d'arrêter suffit d'être bien
malade
vous voyez beaucoup de danseuse dans vos
émissions n'ont voulu dupont peut
traquer ravissante à leur poser une
question très marrante
est ce que vous préférez un amant qui
est un amant qui faisant l'amour mais
qu'un fidèle ou un amant toi maman qui
est fidèle qui fait mal l'amour comme
elle merci merci et à bientôt
et pour être sûr
raté le in a l'habitude abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu